how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday we were told that we were
going to be getting some kind of a
preview for spider-man no way home
from total film magazine and well they
kind of
gave us a little bit of a preview not
really they teased us with a little bit
you can check out my video from
yesterday to hear more about it but
we actually got some true reveals from
the sony motion pictures president
about the spider-verse and about the
connection that the
mcu spider-verse is going to have with
the sony picture universe of
marvel characters and this is coming
from the president himself
in an interview with variety so it's
pretty much as official as it gets
and the crazy thing is is that in this
interview it pretty much confirms the
spiderverse
it pretty much confirms it as much as
you can without straight up coming out
and saying
hey toby and andrew yeah they're in this
movie they're gonna fight alongside tom
holland but there is just
a ton of information in this interview
including
whether or not tom holland spider-man is
ever going to interact with venom
carnage morbius and craven the hunter in
fact in this interview it pretty much
tells us to expect the sinister sex
so i'll break it all down but a reminder
only two days left in my stormbreaker
giveaway all you have to do to enter
subscribe to my channel and to cosmic
culture and leave a comment on the video
so if you didn't catch the news that
came out a couple of days ago
sony has officially cast aaron taylor
johnson the one and only who plays
quicksilver in the mcu
or played i guess sony cast aaron taylor
johnson as
craven now this isn't craven that's
going to be in spiderman no way home
this is a craven the hunter solo film
and this article starts off by talking
about the fact that yes
they have cast him as craven but then
this article kind of starts to mention
the
other characters they start to mention
the venom movie coming out let there be
carnage they start to mention
morbius and then they start to talk
about the fact that spider-man
specifically tom holland spider-man has
yet to be involved in
any of these movies and when they talked
about that separation
the sony pictures motion picture group
president
sanford panic said this we don't really
think
of our 900 characters as the spidey
verse
we have a marvel universe the volume of
characters we have
you know wait until you see this next
venom
you don't miss spider-man that's a
pretty huge statement first of all the
fact that there are 900 different
characters in the spider-man universe
alone is pretty insane
but he also specifically mentions the
marvel universe which is the
mcu and he specifically states that you
don't miss
spider-man and venom let there be
carnage now we know that sony wanted
spider-man
in the very first venom film or at least
they wanted peter parker to make a cameo
however according to the deal that they
had at the time marvel studios said
no because they didn't want them to
confuse the two different universes
but we know since then marvel and disney
made a new deal with sony and from what
we know it does seem like the new deal
is going to allow tom holland's
spider-man to go between the mcu
and the sp umc and even the president of
marvel studios kevin feige
came out and said that spider-man was
the only character who had the ability
to travel between
different universes so he's even hinted
towards the fact that yes
this is the new deal and here's the
kicker panic
after he said you don't miss spider-man
in the next venom film
he paused after that and then he said
it'll be exciting
if they do meet right teasing us once
again
but he also goes on to be a lot more
specific when talking about
spider-man now the article goes on to
talk about how
tom holland's peter parker exist in the
mcu
and any appearance that he might make in
any other of sony's films
like craven venom let there be carnage
or morbius might be
a little confusing and could even be
frustrating for some fans and they start
to address the fact that
it's already actually got confusing
because we saw michael keaton's vulture
in morbius but here's the deal panich
goes on to say
that he understands the confusion and
frustration among the fans
and although of course he didn't give
any specific details he did say
that he expects that the tension will
soon be resolved
and that green lighting craven a
character who's
also tussled with venom in the comics
fills in
another piece of that puzzle he
specifically states
there actually is a plan i think now
maybe it's getting a little more clear
for people where we're headed and i
think when
no way home comes out even more will be
revealed and i mean obviously it kind of
seems like no way home is going to be
what really
opens everything up not only the
multiverse in the mcu but also this
multiverse leading into the sp umc
and the sinister six is even teased here
in this interview which i'll get to in
just a bit
but first one of the most important
parts that we have to talk about here is
what variety states in their article
this is what they said one of the worst
kept secrets in hollywood is that
no way home will be diving headfirst
into the multiverse
and incorporating characters from sony's
earlier spider-man movies that starred
toby maguire and andrew garfield alfred
molina for example
told variety in april that he will be
digitally de-aged in no way home to look
like he did
as the villain doc ock at the end of
2004's spider-man 2. now that right
there
is huge and is very revealing as it is
but
not as revealing as what the supposed
text originally said
now on twitter there are a bunch of
screenshots going around
of this exact same paragraph that is
edited a little differently it's
supposedly what it originally said but
then variety changed the
wording and if it's true this is what it
originally said
instead of incorporating characters from
sony's earlier spider-man movies that
starred toby maguire and andrew garfield
it apparently said and incorporating
sony's other iterations of spider-man
starring toby maguire
and andrew garfield that's a pretty
absolute statement
and we do have the screenshots of that
and that right there is proof
other iterations of spider-man that's a
confirmation right there but even the
changed version of this article
is still a pretty big confirmation i
mean they even mentioned toby maguire
and andrew garfield by name granted they
were talking about the earlier movies
with them in it
but they are incorporating characters
from those
films into a multiverse that's pretty
much
as big of a confirmation as we can get
obviously he didn't say oh yeah and
toby's coming and andrew's coming and
all the spider-man's are getting
together
but that is essentially what he just
said the only reason he actually
mentioned alfred molina would be
in the film is because we already know
that he already came out and said that
so marvel and sony gave them permission
to
say that in this interview but i mean
this is coming from the sony pictures
motion picture group president it's as
official as it can get
so at this point if toby mcguire and
andrew garfield aren't in the movie then
wow they really really played us because
basically we just got a confirmation
that yeah they are they're taking
characters from
their universes and bringing them into
the next spider-man film
and if they decided to do that and not
take the actual spider-man
of those universes that might go down as
one of the dumbest decisions of all time
now we have more good news when asked
what the future holds for spidey in
marvel studios
panich said this the great thing is we
have this
very excellent relationship with kevin
there's an incredible
sandbox there to play with we want those
mcu movies to be
absolutely huge because that's great for
us and our marvel characters and i think
that's the same thing
on their side but we have a great
relationship
there's lots of opportunities i think
that are going to happen
variety would go on to ask about one of
those opportunities being
finally making a movie about the
sinister six especially with the
announcement of
craven coming to the sp umc in which
panic said
it's tough because i think these
projects are the kind of things we have
to work on
in the dark they're not ready until
they're ready
craven is a great example because we
just didn't rush it
we could have made that three plus years
ago it's just
now the script's awesome jc was the
right choice
and we found the movie star because it
was just kinsment
and watching this other movie and
realizing that could be the perfect
casting but variety pressed a little bit
further asking about the sinister six
and
after a long pause panic chuckled and
said
it would be very cool wouldn't it and i
think that that is absolutely the plan
they're introducing so many different
characters into the sp umc that it just
makes sense that they are setting up the
sinister six right now
and then when you have no way home open
the multiverse and make it to where tom
hall and spider-man can travel to the sp
umc
it makes perfect sense that that's
what's going to happen spider-man
versus the sinister six so pretty big
reveals in this variety article
we basically got a confirmation of the
spider-verse and the sinister six
and one of the best parts is it looks
like marvel and disney and
sony have a really great relationship
which means this universe that is being
created is not going anywhere
but let me know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below let me know
how excited you are for the spider-verse
and spider-man no way home be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spider-man news don't
forget to like the video and of course
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you